Росія посилює обстріли території України.
І в британській, і в українській розвідці застерігають:
обстріли РФ можуть ставати масштабнішими з наближенням зими.
Ціллю знову може стати енергетична інфраструктура України.
А також портИ, зерносховища та інші цивільні об'єкти.
Наскільки українська ППО готова закрити небо?
Що змінилося порівняно з минулою зимою? DW зібрала найголовніше.
Ключова зброя протиповітряної оборони - зенітно-ракетні комплекси.
Раніше на озброєнні України стояли виключно радянські зразки, зокрема, "Бук-М1", С-300.
З осені минулого року з'явилися західні.
Першими - установками NASAMS, потім німецьким IRIS-T,  який показав надзвичайно гарні результати.
Ця система з надзвичайно потужним сучасним радаром,
який бачить геть усе в небі, який дає цілевказання і на інші комплекси,
не лише на пускові установки IRIS, на командні пункти та пускові інших зенітних ракетних систем.
Також станом на жовтень в Україні розгорнуті два американські комплекси Patriot
і один французький SAMP/T.
Вони ефективні і проти ракет, і проти дронів. Утім, їх мало.
Ми сьогодні в ситуації, коли ми змушені захищати саме локально
великі міста-мільйонники, де є об'єкти критичної інфраструктури,
об'єкти атомної енергетики.
Це все потрібно робити локально:
там об'єкт захистили, там, там по Україні, отак от кружечками,
як-то кажуть, простими словами.
Поміж тих кружечків, де вже не є захищена територія, ворог планує свої удари.
До яких російських атак готуватися Україні?
У вересні РФ застосувала рекордну кількість "шахедів"
- 503 дрони за місяць.
До середини жовтня запустили ще понад 200.
РФ б'є по цивільному населенню.
І буде бити по цивільному населенню здебільшого.
По цивільній, навіть не цивільній інфраструктурі, просто по населенню.
Ідеться про першу загрозу - це, звісно, "шахеди", як наймасовішу.
Не найбільшу, а просто наймасовішу загрозу.
"Шахеди" - відносно дешева зброя.
Ці БПЛА зазвичай атакують групами або "роями".
Їхня мета - виснажувати ППО.
У такому разі застосування того ж Patriot - крайній засіб, пояснює Юрій Ігнат.
Вартість "шахеда", ну, нехай там десятки тисяч доларів.
Вартість однієї зенітної керованої ракети - це вже сотні тисяч доларів.
Якщо ми беремо NASAMS, то це до півмільйона.
Тому більш раціонально знищувати "шахеди" саме зенітними гарматами.
Тією зброєю, яка найбільш ефективна.
З такого озброєння ЗСУ має в арсеналі німецькі зенітні самохідні установки "Гепард".
Вони вже зарекомендували себе як ефективні "винищувачі "шахедів".
Радіус ураження Gepard - 4,5 км.
Ось таким чином Gepard може на тій відстані запелінгувати його своїм радаром,
і вже штучний інтелект визначає, як повернути башту,
в який момент висипати з тих двох стволів чергу снарядів,
високошвидкісних, розривних, зенітних боєприпасів,
які стовідсотково його знищують.
Через невеликий радіус дії "Гепарди" називають "малим ППО".
Його можна застосовувати як "зброю останньої надії",
щоб "закрити" ним конкретні об'єкти.
Утім, кількість "Гепардів" в Україні також обмежена.
У Німеччині вони зняті з виробництва.
Питання зі снарядами для цих установок частково вирішене.
Враховуючи те, що 305-мм боєприпас, який використовується в "Гепардах" для системи "Ерлікон",
доволі популярна річ насправді у світі.
Тому багато хто поставив питання: що буде, якщо в нас буде війна?
І відповів Rheinmetall.
Він розпочав виробництво цих боєприпасів у Німеччині.
Банально через те, що він розуміє попит.
Альтернативою "Гепардам" можуть слугувати й низка західних систем.
Наприклад, одна з найбільш досконалих систем ППО малого радіусу дії
Skynex виробництва того ж Rheinmetall.
У жовтні Великобританія оголосила про передачу Україні
комплексів ППО ближньої дії Terrahawk Paladin.
Це теж надсучасне озброєння. В Україні комплекс застосовуватиметься вперше.
Як і німецький "Гепард", британський "Паладін" оглядач Олег Катков
називає ефективною "шахедобійкою".
Буквально два роки тому був лише продемонстрований дослідний зразок,
тобто це не те, що передають зі складів
чи зі строю певних збройних сил - це система, яка замовляється.
Аналогічна ситуація відносно постачання бойових модулів Slinger від австралійської EOS.
Будь-яка країна, яка знаходиться у стані війни,
не може собі дозволити таку розкіш мирного часу, як одноманітність.
Там, де бракує техніки, її замінюють люди.
Аби збивати російські дрони, Україна застосовує мобільні вогневі групи.
Їх називають "мисливцями за "шахедами".
В уряді повідомляли, що напередодні зими нарощується кількість таких груп.
Юрій Ігнат називає це вимушеним кроком.
Це люди на пікапах, люди на вантажівках, озброєні зенітними установками ще радянського зразка:
ЗУ-23-2.
Так само озброєні кулеметами крупнокаліберними,
такими, як ДШК, "Утьос" та інші - це те, що ефективно.
Це оптичні приціли, це тепловізійне обладнання, тепловізори, це прожектори,
це лазерні системи, які допомагають, ну, власне, прицілюватись і влучно відпрацьовувати.
Якщо до протистояння з безпілотниками українські військові
дещо призвичаїлися, то однією з найбільших небезпек залишаються
російські керовані ракети С-300 і С-400, балістичні ракети "Іскандер",
та аеробалістичні "Кинджали".
Росія нарощує їхнє виробництво.
Щоб збивати такі ракети, Україні потрібно більше західних систем ППО.
Балістика є балістика.
Зрозуміло, що немає в нас засобів достатньо, щоб протистояти.
У нас їх практично взагалі немає.
Якщо говорити - це два підрозділи, два дивізіони чи дві батареї, як кажуть на заході,
"Петріот", то цього замало, щоб перекривати такі великі території.
За словами Олега Каткова, щоб повністю закрити небо принаймні над великими містами,
у комному необхідно поставити принаймні дві системи на кшталт "Петріот".
Але є й інший вихід.
Ситуація могла бути інакшою, якби Захід зняв свою нелюдяну умову
не використовувати його озброєння по території Російської Федерації.
Тому що без ураження пускових, без ураження аеродромів,
у тому числі навіть якщо ми говоримо про тактичну авіацію,
тобто в Курській та Брянській областях, нівелювати цю загрозу вкрай складно.
У Повітряних силах наголошують:
Україна розпочала перехід до ППО виключно західного зразка.
Адже хоча снаряди для таких систем дорогі й дефіцитні,
ракети для радянської техніки теж вичерпуються - і в Україні, і за кордоном.
Винищувачі F-16 доповнять вже доступні Україні системи IRIS-T,
Patriot, NASAMS і SAMP/T.
За словами речника Повітряних сил Юрія Ігната,
українські пілоти, які тренуються для польотів на F-16,
за кілька тижнів почнуть літати на навчальних бойових літаках.
За оптимістичними прогнозами, F-16 з'являться в Україні в першій половині 2024 року.